hello everyone I'm Dana Pino along with
judge Janine pero here's Morgan Jesse
Waters and Brian Kil meet it's 5 o'clock
in New York City and this is the
[Music]
five Fox News Alert the massive Manhunt
underway in Maine authorities still
desperately searching for Robert card
he's the suspect believed to have shot
and killed 18 people in Maine and
injuring 13 others dozens of FBI agents
aiding local and state officials in
their ongoing search and residents
continue to shelter in place in multiple
counties Nate Foy live on the scene in
Leon Maine Nate what is the latest on
the search for
card well Dana 22 hours into this
Manhunt authorities are still spread out
across multiple counties trying to find
the man who they say is responsible for
the worst mass shooting in Maine's
history right now uh there is a
scattered presence but one specific
place that we're watching uh is where
card lives in Bowden main take a live
look at this this is 25 miles east of
where we are in Lewiston and 25 miles
farther east on the coast Dana the US
Coast Guard confirms that it's following
up on a possible sighting in Booth Bay
Harbor they're using aviation units
there and the town over from this camera
near card's home is called Lisbon take a
look at this that's where card's vehicle
was found near a boat landing where he
is right now now is anyone's guess
there's no defined search perimeter
there's a shelter and place order that
stretches across multiple counties card
is Accused you mentioned of murdering 18
people at two different locations and
injuring 13 people those two locations
were a bowling alley and a bar three of
the 13 injured are still in critical
condition Now card is a trained firearm
instructor he's a member of the Army
Reserve and he has documented mental
health issues all that has people in
this area very scared of what he might
do
next I slept on and off for about 2
three hours moving forward how do we
move forward feeling as a community
we're we're numb we're hurt we're you
know like how how can you feel safe
again how can we send our kids to
school yeah Dana right now Lewiston is a
ghost town pretty much every single
business is closed the only people that
you see out are me MERS of the media as
well as law enforcement we do have a
press conference coming up uh with
Senator Susan Collins at 6:00 so we'll
see what she has to say uh but right now
everyone is just hoping for good news
we'll send it back to you thank you Nate
and Jesse you have a lot of ties to
Maine this a state that you know well
and an area that you visited yeah we
have a house right north of Booth Bay
Harbor where there was just a sighting
We Believe of this gentleman shouldn't
call him a gentleman but this individual
and there's a lot of Patriots there a
lot of heavily armed Patriots there that
are going to be well protected and that
are going to call police immediately if
they see something suspicious we now
have the Coast Guard involved but Dana
if you elongate the coast of Maine it's
basically the entire length of the
United States and where this guy is in
Livingston which is a little I
guess Inland you could say there are
rivers that feed right out into the
water and it's densely forested and so
this terrain is wretched it's e easy to
hide in and he may have had a cabin
somewhere and you know he has an ATV he
probably has a canoe this guy looks like
he planned it so he could be North he
could be South he could be stashed away
we don't know where he is but I'm a
little concerned about this I don't like
the fact that someone's involuntarily
committed to a menal institution and no
one initiates a process to take away his
firearms that is insane to me and
whoever didn't initiate that process to
take this guy's Firearms away has blood
on their hands and we don't know a lot
about what's going on right now but that
right there is your patriotic duty if
you're sending someone to a mental
institution for two weeks because
they're saying they're hearing voices
and because they're going to shoot up an
army base they have to make that known
to the right authorities so they strip
this guy of his weapon so everybody can
be safe judge what about either that law
or what do you think the police in terms
of the coordination that is going on
right now to try to find him uh first of
all U this is a guy who was trained to
avoid capture all right 90% of Maine is
Forest so this guy is one step ahead of
law enforcement and there's a huge
problem the drones and infrared
technology will be you know they'll have
a problem because of all of the forestry
the trees and everything else so I mean
the layout of this situation is a bad
one to begin with uh but what we have
here is apparently a a process where the
US military has no obligation to report
to law
enforcement uh that there is a problem
whether it is a mental health issue with
a soldier or an army reservist as this
guy was so um it's it's it's not unlike
with the priest years ago they said well
we handle it within the church we don't
have an obligation to report to Civil
Authorities apparently the Department of
Defense does not require uh the army or
anyone else to report to local law
enforcement when there's a problem and
that's where the slip up there was a
real slip up here my understanding
according to a well-placed US Army
official is he was assigned to the Army
reserve unit sent for training at West
Point this July to support summer
training but there are no records that
he participated in the training
apparently on the first day of training
at West Point they wouldn't say why but
he was removed although open- Source
reporting suggest erratic Behavior so
then he goes into this mental health U
uh part of the uh hospital I think it's
called the uh Carter Keller Army
hospital on the West Point uh base and
there's very little that's done after
that so that is there was a slip up
there that did not have to happen
there's another piece that I think is
important here and that is that we made
a decision uh in the 70s and maybe even
before that that we were going to start
shutting down these mental health
institutions because a lot of them were
abusive um you know there were people
there that were mistreated and instead
of upgrading mental health institutions
we literally unloaded people who were
mentally uh unfit onto the streets and
we are now suffering the results of that
here's Morgan you um have you're here
with perhaps a view on gun control in
the United States but also um you and
come from a country that doesn't have a
lot of gun violence have other kind of
violence because violent people will
commit these types of things and one
question before you talk about anything
you want to talk about um does Britain
allow for the
involuntary institutionalization of
people if they have mental health
problems like this I think you can be
voluntarily or involuntarily uh put into
a mental institution absolutely I mean
what I would say generally look first of
all my heart goes out to all these
families because once again you're
seeing similar imagery of a shooter with
one of these semi-automatic rifles and a
lot of lives have been lost a lot of
people's lives have been ruined and
families are grieving and mourning and
it's it's heartbreaking secondly as I
learned the hard way uh over the years
Americans don't really take to uh my
accent or somebody called peers
lecturing them about how to lead their
lives or about their their culture or
about their laws I get that um but you
made a point there that in England we
just don't have guns I mean hardly
anybody has guns including criminals
right so I think we've had one mass
shooting in like 5 years or something
you've had God knows how many this year
alone and it just goes on it's kind of
Groundhog Day and there's the old I
don't think actually Einstein ever said
this quote about the definition of
insanity is doing the same thing over
and over again and expecting a different
result but actually in this case I would
argue as a friend to American American
someone that loves the country and loves
the people at some point you've got to
do something more than you're doing and
I wouldn't use the word control I think
that's part of the problem with this
whole debate when Americans hear the
word control M they they think
instinctively federal government control
and it alienates any chance of any
compromise gun safety is the way this
should be debated how do you make it
safer how do you stop these loopholes
these guys slipping through the net it's
obviously a catastrophic failure in
Maine they have yellow flags not red
flags why why why don't you just have a
red flag system all over the country
country you have 400 million plus guns
in circulation a million new guns are
sold every month in America this
problem's going to get worse not better
and at some point as your friend you
know as the great Ally I simply say
you've got to do something more to stop
this you can't keep having the groundhog
day of these people with these
semi-automatic rifles going into
civilian areas and gunning people to
pieces can you as your friend
respectfully of course we have these
guns because of you because of your
country because of your king I know and
we haven't had that problem with a king
since then I know with respect as your
friend respectfully here's my response I
cannot buy in the United States of
America a Kinder surprise chocolate egg
they're banned they're banned on safety
grounds because the little toys inside
them might choke people a British prime
minister I won't say which one but one
in the last last few years told me he
was stopped at LAX because he had some
for his nieces and They confiscated them
because they were a health hazard now I
simply say you're a country of many
freedoms and many regulations how about
regulating guns in the way that you do
Kinder surprise chocolate eggs okay with
respect with with respect do Forks make
people fat uh yeah okay no well they do
they do don't they guns don't kill
people
people kill people guns Forks don't make
you fat pet guns do kill people Forks
don't make you fat want to jump in Brian
yeah uh a couple of things just on this
in particular his family spoke out they
were asking him to surrender NBC is
reporting that there was a note found
they don't know what the note says they
haven't said anything yet they do know
that he has registered a a watercraft so
this guy could have planned an escape he
seems very organized it looks like he's
got a personal attachment to both these
places he wasn't just randomly shooting
it up you see pictures of him on
Facebook he's bowling in the past uh I
look forward to some of these people
coming forward I do see that somebody
who served with him 10 of his first 20
years said he was a commander that was
always calm great to be with they felt
like they grew up with each other so
something clearly went wrong and about
our system uh this guy's going to get a
gun regardless this guy's a military guy
knows how to get him and all these
experts and I'm not a gun expert or a
rful expert I'd never taken anyone down
or hunted someone down or took out a
deer but the way he handles the gun the
way he moved uh they say he is absolute
Pro and turns out he's an instructor he
was going to get a gun anyway but there
was a system in place to stop him he was
institutionalized just like the same
system in place that says after 10 days
you are now cured from your addiction
well what happens is your insurance runs
out and all of a sudden they go okay uh
you're still an alcoholic but we only
have 10 days for you to stay here
because we need your bed you're out of
here so this guy was stopped he was
hearing voices he was rounded up and and
they did take you know they the problem
is when he got out when he got out they
did not take his guns away there's
something with that because in that with
that shooter that should happen can I
jump in because there is some breaking
news that we have um there is apparently
David spunt I think is with us from doj
we have Fox digital is on the ground
there apparently there some loud bangs
and Davis SP are you there no you're not
there okay so he is saying that there
might be some action here guys so we are
going to keep a close eye on you know
that's where his house is too right yes
and so um we will try to get David spunt
and more information for but if I can
respond to what was just being said they
have a yellow flag law in Maine the
yellow flag law in Maine different from
a red flag law requires law enforcement
to detain the individual get a medical
professional to come in and say he's a
danger to himself or others now if the
Army doesn't tell law enforcement that
there's a problem law enforcement isn't
going to find the medical person to
detain him and to find out and to then
enter him into a program two weeks is
Never Enough for anything in terms of
getting someone better yeah so judge
would I would say this somebody put him
in there uh so was it the military that
put him in there military put Army based
hospital but the difference between the
flag system as I understand it is with
yellow flags families can't notify a
judge directly right and that's in a red
flag they can yeah so in this case his
family knew he was severely mentally
Disturbed they knew he owned guns they
knew that he had publicly threatened to
commit a mass like Nashville by and this
is by the way all in the last three
months right I mean I'm not sure how
many more Flags this guy had to raise
but because the system didn't allow his
family to go directly to a judge as it
would under a red flag system so I
simply say what why not make red flag
system mandatory the family can go to
law enforcement there there is that they
had the freedom to do that in every
state as long as law enforcement then
gets a medical professional who assesses
him and says he's a
danger in a red flag system it's the
judge that makes that calculation but
the cop has I was the judge who made
that calculation but the cop has to
bring me the person and in order to get
that person you need law enforcement to
bring him in so Danny you're still
following what David spun saying right
uh which basically he might have heard
something there might have been a bang
and what you're seeing right now is new
video that is just in the FBI is and
local police of course they are outside
the last known address there is a loud
bang apparently the FBI is trying to
make contact as they believe that Robert
card may be inside that is the reporting
that we are getting from David spun he
is our correspondent at the justice
department we're trying to get him up
with us here in a moment we have Fox
News digital on the ground there
reporting as well so we're going to keep
talking about this year because there's
obviously plenty going on that would
surprise me knowing what we know about
this guy and how well trained he is that
he would go back to his last address
after murdering a slew of people in the
middle of a manh running out of his car
with then leaving his door wide open
that doesn't seem like something he
would do either he's in total insane
person and he would go back home some
people go back home after shooting
people and put some chicken in the oven
uh but something tells me this is not
him I could be wrong but this be the
last place you would go during a man
although his family his family did say I
think it was his sister said that he was
having these episode periods really bad
mental health episodes and then he would
be perfectly normal and she felt that
when he was if he could get back to a
place of normality after this he would
feel so bad at what what he' done but
that's not enough do something that's
not enough the fact that if it is if he
is in his home that shows that uh he is
not connected to reality because anyone
who has done that would know that I have
to abcon I have to get away so whenever
for example I had an insanity defense as
a prosecutor I was that's great he was
crazy when he killed a woman but then he
knew to get away get a gun get a boat
take a ride you know this may show that
he's more insane than we think something
I mean you're Americans right it's your
country these are happening on on your
watch out of Interest I mean how do you
feel about
this incessant volume of really
catastrophic mass shootings what what do
you think should be done well I actually
just purchased my first Firearms last
week and it was a big moment for me as
an American I'd never done it before I
grew up in Philadelphia we weren't a
family that came from Guns my father
grew up in Hartford Connecticut it
wasn't something that we did but now
we're out in the country and if you have
a young family peers and you're out in
the middle of the woods I get it you
can't call 911 and just hope for the
best you have to defend your family and
so everybody thinks that way especially
in a place like Maine as we said talk
about densely populated is more densely
forested in Maine than Alaska wow so you
make a phone call if someone's at your
door or on your premises you're waiting
maybe sometimes 15 20 minutes for police
to show up that is valuable time if
you're trying to defend your family your
children or your property you need a
weapon and maybe you need an AR-15
because you have to have something
semi-automatic and you have to have
something accurate that you can handle
well in a tight spot so so what my
question is I get that and I remember
Bill Mah arguing the same that he bought
a firearm because he thought he had to
be able to defend himself in a country
where a lot of people have guns I get it
we don't have them in N just told
everyone in Israel to get a gun right so
I completely understand why people in
America feel the need to arm themselves
to defend themselves and their family
that's not my question my question is
the volume of these mass shootings is
increasing the volume of guns being sold
each month is massively increasing
mental health problems seem to be
increasing overmedication seems to be
increasing it's a lethal cocktail that's
getting worse not better I you're smart
people I just wonder what does America
do about this what America has to do is
we have to start making sure that people
who get guns are not mentally unfit to
have them there are HIPPA laws in the
United States that prevent a lot of this
information from being garnered but the
truth is peers we are so far down the
road where in Chicago every guy's got an
illegal gun every criminal does that we
have to get guns to protect ourselves my
son my son is here he was at Chicago
University last year and a couple of
students were shot while he was there I
mean you know Chicago is an absolute B
to build on what you're saying and to
build on what your point is it's a
mental illness issue because we did not
have this problem until the last 15 20
years colbi was really the first we
always had because we had more guns we
had less regulation than we had right
now I didn't grow up in a gun culture
but I appreciate that it's one of our
rights I'm not looking to to give it
away and what happens is when you crack
down on regulation because we all have
the same objective to never have this
happen again when you crack down on
regulation you just stop the People Like
Us that would buy a gun and abide the
laws we're going to get the permits
we're going to go to the range we're
going to get the training we will make
sure it's in a lock box we're not the
problem but more regulations clamped
down so we continue to change our lives
if the gun is in your culture and your
choice while The Reckless Luna
like this guy to shed so I get that
completely I completely understand that
logic and it makes perfect sense right I
get it but what do you do then what can
you do to stop this ever increasing
volume of real massacr because they are
increasing in in size scale death toll
but this guy would have been caught had
had the had the Army notified law
enforcement you know it was like 911
when what what the CIA wasn't talking to
the FBI you know now they're talking to
each other now you have to have the Army
notify local authorities all right
that's one legislative change right off
the bat and we've got to make it easier
as you say uh to make sure that we can
bring people before judges who are a
danger to the themselves or others there
are a lot of people who are not well we
saw it during the pandemic they're
walking around on the streets stabbing
people shooting people even though we
have a lot of people that very Pro
second amendment in this country over 60
to 70% are concerned about this as
Republicans and Democrats let me grab
David spunt now who I've been looking
for he's our phon friend here today
David spunt has more details about
what's happening right now in Maine hi
David hi Dana hi everyone so we're told
right now that uh they are at a couple
of properties that uh are associated
with Robert card the suspect and a
source just told me over the phone that
these are likely flashbangs this is uh
standard procedure to try to see if he
is inside uh to make comment uh or or to
make contact rather to have him come out
and uh come into custody I asked whether
or not they would have obviously looked
at this these homes earlier today
because these addresses have been known
to law enforcement and actually known to
uh members of the public and members of
the media by just doing a simple Google
search uh earlier today and yes they
have been at the homes earlier but for
some reason now uh they are using
flashbangs I was told not to read into
anything specifically meaning that he's
going to walk out or he's necessarily
inside uh but it's always been a concern
Dana and everyone that this man Robert
card has had a scanner or several police
scanners and is clearly listening uh
potentially to every move that law
enforcement is making so just kind of to
wrap it up this is in Bowden Maine uh
there are several locations in Bowden
where uh properties rather that are
connected to Robert card uh the suspect
no longer Person of Interest the suspect
and we are hearing flashbangs at this
point and will continue to update and
this is coming from one of our Fox
digital Crews on the
scene Davis B thanks for rushing to the
studio for us we appreciate that we will
continue to monitor breaking details on
the Manhunt for the main shooter hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else